grab your jet packs and prepare to say
goodbye I mean come on how can you let
this little guy go because we have
episode three of the Mandalorian and we
have a ton of new info to dissect you're
gonna want to stick around till the end
of the video as we'll be going over all
the possibilities of where the
Mandalorian is headed next on his quest
so buckle up because here we go the
episode begins right where we left off
in episode 2 the razor crest has arrived
on the still unnamed planet from episode
1 we get some great planetary shots of
its rolling hills of magma of which this
city is built on the planet is
essentially a metaphor for the galaxy
unstable chaotic and violent grief carga
the head of the bounty hunters guild on
the planet is pleased that the
Mandalorian has acquired the quarry an
old French word for an animal or thing
pursued by hunters upon delivery the
Mandalorian will have earned an
impressive Hall and the client is
extremely antsy to finally get his hands
on this asset will learn a bit more
about that later on the Mandalorian
lands and I keep saying this every
episode but I love the random shots of
these citizens allowing us to get a feel
for the world were on like this Twilight
here just chilling I wonder if she works
at the - I like baths oh the Mandalorian
arrives at the client's with the asset
even telling one of the budget
stormtroopers here to be careful with
him or her or I don't know what pronoun
to use these small comments show that
the Mandalorian genuinely cares for the
child and it's these tiny gestures like
handing him the chrome top to play with
at the end of the episode that show the
Mandalorian isn't just some bounty
hunter obsessed with money and only in
it for himself
there's a part of him that cares the
client is extremely pleased with the
Mandalorians work and dr. Pershing gives
him a quick look over to see that he's
in good health there's also a theory
going around online that dr. Pershing is
a Kamino cloner the emblem he wears on
his arm is the same found on those who
work at the Kaminoan cloning facility in
attack of the clones so whomever his
boss is likely is wanting to clone these
baby Yoda's we learned that it was the
client who sent multiple bounty hunters
after the asset he had to ensure the
assets delivery to his own boss with
rumors swirling
this person is an imperial or even
Palpatine himself
this means IG 11 and the trend oceans he
fought were likely sent by the client
and if I G 11 was sent by the client
that means the client actually wants the
child dead as IG 11 was given
termination orders we know from Episode
one that the client doesn't care if the
asset is brought back alive or not
contrary to dr. Pershing alas the
Mandalorian claims his prize aching Tona
abbess curse stele if you want to know a
little bit more about the lore behind a
Cantona and why it's actually an ice
cream machine check out my episode 1
breakdown
dr. Pershing whisks the child away and
the mandalorian goes against the Bounty
Hunter code by asking the client what's
to be done with it
according to bounty hunter code once a
payment is accepted the job is not to be
spoken of again it's a big no-no to ask
what is to happen to the bounty the
client suggests the Mandalorian gets
some new best car armor but finding
another Mandalorian to help Forge it may
be difficult but how is this possible
since we saw a bunch of them in episode
1 well that's because they're hidden in
a base known as the covert only emerging
when absolutely necessary an event
happened years ago called the Great
Purge which saw the Mandalorians hunted
by the Empire hence the lot of them in
hiding and the importance they place on
providing for the foundlings the next
generation of Mandalorians many of whom
were orphaned by the purge this begs the
question was the Mandalorian also a
victim of this purge when he goes back
to the armorer we once again are treated
to flashbacks from when he was a child
being protected by what we can assume
are his parents in these flashbacks we
can make out super battle droids
originally used by the Trade Federation
during the Clone Wars the Trade
Federation as we know would later be
nationalized by the Empire after Darth
Vader killed nute Gunray its leader
so it's possible these droids are under
control of the Empire at this time and
this is part of the great purge this
also begs the question does he come from
a long line of Mandalorians all we
really know about the Mandalorian is
that he himself was a foundling so I
guarantee the history of his real
heritage will be revealed later down the
line either way with the Empire gone the
Mandalorian still live in fear
being hunted we get the title of this
episode the sin which in my opinion is a
reference to the Mandalorian committing
the worst sin a bounty hunter can do
which is to go against the code when he
goes to forge his new armor he's
surrounded by his fellow Mandalorian who
don't take too kindly to the steel he's
acquired being emblazoned with the
Imperial sigil but it's the armor Smith
who intercedes reciting the way of the
Mandalore and it's here we learn a
little more about the Mandalorian
culture for example she tells him she
can forge Acuras worthy of his station
suggesting the Mandalorians have a
class-based system she talks about the
importance of not removing his helmet he
said he's never removed it and has never
had it removed but knowing what we see
in the trailers this may not last for
long
and finally we learn about the forging
of his signet the signet is a symbol of
a Mandalorian victory and his defeat of
the mud horn would constitute him being
worthy of one but the Mandalorian
refuses since the way dictates one must
not be helped by others and he was
helped by the child a child whom he
calls the enemy in a very bad attempt to
justify that he just gave him away
instead of the Signet the armor will
Forge whistling birds a weapon will
later seen used by him to take out in
multiple stormtroopers and as the way
dictates part of the steel will be put
towards the foundlings the Mandalorian
culture it seems puts great emphasis on
helping their orphaned which may
contribute to why the Mandalorian cares
so much about the child while the armors
forged we get more flashbacks of our
young Mandalorian and his protectors
their robes suggest they are of a higher
station than the other civilians around
them the parents seemingly die
off-screen as a super battle droid finds
the boy with its weapon raised does this
mean the Mandalorian was raised by
someone in the Empire or is he saved by
someone else there are tons of crazy
theories out there including that he'll
be saved by obi-wan Kenobi especially
considering Deborah Chou the director
will also be helming a lot of those
episodes or it could be another Jedi or
most likely it will be a Mandalorian
hence why he becomes one but I'm
guessing this won't be the last time we
see more of these flashbacks the
Mandalorian visits grief and is a little
pissed he failed to tell them about the
other murderous bounty hunters on the
same job but such as the life of a
bounty hunter
the
is also where we hear our first mention
of the New Republic which is the power
in charge at the moment and will later
be antagonized by the first order mando
is ready to get far away from this place
taking the furthest possible bounty but
the mandalorian can't seem to get the
child off his mind perhaps it's the fact
he witnessed him using inexplicable
power lifting the mud horn or that he
too is an orphan and can relate to a
child being taken away regardless he
decides to venture back to the client
for some reconnaissance he sees the pod
in the trash and stakes out the client -
we hear over talking to dr. Pershing
client wants to extract the quote and
necessary material and be done with it
and the doctor reiterates their explicit
orders to bring the being back alive
but what necessary material is the
client referring to the first thing that
comes to mind are midi-chlorians
microscopic life forms that can be found
in the blood which bind to their hosts
in communicate with the force this could
work with the theory that the person
behind all this is Emperor Palpatine
needing to regain his power since he'll
be in the rise of Skywalker the other
thing they could be extracting is
something specific to the child and
Yoda's species it would be something we
haven't heard of yet but for now
midi-chlorians seems to be the
prevailing theory the Mandalorian isn't
too subtle in his approach blowing a
hole into the side of the building
showing off the power of his grappling
line by raking in his storm trooper we
also see the strength of Bester steel
being able to guard from blaster fire
the Mandalorian makes his way to dr.
Pershing who's in the middle of his
tests even the droid with the syringe
here is a callback to the interrogation
droid found in a new hope
at first the doctor thinks the
Mandalorian is here to kill the child
and he tells the Mandalorian he was
simply trying to protect it and to the
doctor surprise his life is spared as
the Mandalorian makes his escape dozens
of tracking fobs of jealous bounty
hunters go off not only does the
Mandalorian have the asset but also a
shit-ton of Bester steel he's basically
a walking mistermonopoli he stopped by
grief and the other bounty hunters and
is told to put the child down this is a
serious violation of the Bounty Hunter's
code but the Mandalorian doesn't agree
and commandeered a speeder to escape
which is shot down by grief with
seemingly nowhere to go things look grim
for our hero when out
the blue a gang of Jetpack wielding
Mandalorians come to save the day
they have come to protect their own the
Mandalorians provide cover for mando to
escape but lo and behold if it isn't
grief cargo who is waiting for him the
Mandalorian uses his grappling line to
turn on the carbonate giving him some
much-needed cover before he blasts
griefs ass out of the hole but
unfortunately for the Mandalorian will
likely see grief again who was saved by
his own greed literally he's saved by
the best cursed eel he earned the
Mandalorians make sure mando has a safe
getaway with him even saying he has to
get one of those jet packs that will be
sweet but where could the mandalorian be
off to well I think it's safe to say he
won't be picking up that Mon Calamari
bounty wherever he's going will either
be somewhere safe that he knows he can't
be tracked or someplace where he can
find out more information about this kid
in the trailers we also get this image
of the razor crest taking fire in space
which could mean his shipmate crash land
on another planet which is where we may
find Carradine or bill burrs character
who I suspect is part of a band of
smugglers regardless a slew of bounty
hunters will be tracking the Mandalorian
as the armorsmith said one chooses to
walk the way of the Mandalore you are
both hunter and it looks like this time
he's the prey that's it for this
episode's breakdown for smash that like
button and leave me a comment below
about what you think might happen next
you can also follow me on Twitter at
pings story YT until next time remember
daddy loves you very much